[Music]
Aretha Franklin commanded respect and
boy did she get it the 18th time
grammy-winning legend performed at three
presidential inaugurations and for the
pope the 76 year old music legend passed
away today in her Detroit home we have
new details on her final days as tonight
we remember the Queen of Soul
I think just being yourself being an
original that sets you apart from
everyone else from Hollywood to Harlem
and everywhere around the world
are--those fans paid tribute today the
legendary soul singer died from an
advanced form of pancreatic cancer
Aretha chose to keep her health issues
private you can't control what people
say you just can't I'm feeling
fabulously well fabulous I'm ready to
get on and get it on this was a Rita's
last public performance
[Music]
it was for Elton John's AIDS Foundation
gala in New York last November today
Elton said he cried during the
performance adding she was obviously
unwell and I wasn't sure she could
perform but Aretha did and she raised
the roof the queen is dead long live the
Queen
Aretha early years weren't easy pregnant
at the age of 12 she had two children by
the time she was 14 her first husband
was reportedly abusive and her father
was shot by an intruder and spent his
final five years in a coma the pain
fueled her music the church and these
different arenas and auditoriums that we
had services in were the training ground
for me Aretha was an icon for feminism
and civil rights she sang at dr. Martin
Luther King Jr's funeral and in her last
et interview she told us she wanted to
be remembered for her music and her
humanitarian work before you can be a
great ory good anything else you've got
to be a good person
[Music]